und jetzt das heute journal
richter görgen die skate aid
die narben das ist heute am 22 dezember
jetzt genau 30 jahre her dass diese
utopie realität wurde geschaffen nicht
vom präsidenten reden sondern von
millionen deutschen in der ddr die nicht
länger bereit waren sich ihr
menschenrecht nehmen zu lassen
meinungsfreiheit und die freiheit zu
reisen und sei es zu fuß durch ein tor
in der mitte ihrer stadt
am 22
dezember 1989 mädchen noch selbstbewusst
die fahne der ddr
hunderttausende sind gekommen
zur öffnung des brandenburger tores
trotz des regens nie so ganz fein und
krochen durch alle klamotten durch und
die leute standen hier rundherum auf dem
platze aber in der mitte war ein großes
freies carré und da saß du nach kurzer
zeit als es immer kleiner wurde
und die leute die volkspolizei so
wegdrängen und schließlich gab es ein
einteiler ende des chaos es sei wohl der
endpunkt der auflösung der ddr gewesen
so mamba und es ist einer dieser
gänsehaut momente im herbst winter 89
wer mit der mauer 28 jahre erlebt hat
empfindet heute den tag als wäre
silvester und heiligabend zur gleichen
zeit gekommen das stadttor ein ort mit
symbolkraft und wechselvoller geschichte
erinnert hans modrow damaliger
ministerpräsident der ddr
und ich habe deutlich gesagt und ich
muss sagen das bewegt mich bis heute
weiter hier an dieser stelle soll nicht
wieder krieg soll nicht wie sie darauf
von kriegen und leichen seien sondern
wir brauchen frieden und wir brauchen
gerade hier eine mahnung die wir
mitnehmen
im zweiten weltkrieg schwer beschädigt
stießen hier am brandenburger tor die
politischen systeme aneinander
mit dem mauerbau war das tor
jahrzehntelang unzugänglich 1987
forderte us präsident reagan hier die
öffnung des tores
die mauer sie fällt im november 89
doch erst über einen monat später öffnen
ministerpräsident modrow und
bundeskanzler kohl gemeinsam mit den
bürgermeistern von ost und west berlin
das tor
[Musik]
die berliner sie freuten sich und aus
dem symbol der teilung deutschlands dem
brandenburger tor ist heute das symbol
des vereinten deutschlands geworden
30 jahre man könnte also auch sagen eine
generation später ist die vision des
alten grundgesetzes die
wiedervereinigung in frieden und
freiheit immer noch nicht ganz vollendet
immer noch im werden
das hat 2009 10 noch einmal eindrücklich
gezeigt den drei ostdeutschen
landtagswahlen
wenn es nach prozentzahlen geht darum
geht es nun mal in demokratien ist die
afg im osten in die liga der
volksparteien aufgestiegen
ob sie es in ihrer sprache ihre zusammen
und zielsetzung ist ist immer noch
gegenstand des streits der
bundestagspräsident steht einem
parlament vor dass mit diesen
verhältnissen noch erfahrungen sammelt
aber auch schon erfahrungen gemacht hat
guten abend herr schäuble
guten abend der kleber in den zwei
jahren afd im bundestag hat sich eine
klare spaltung durchgesetzt so groß der
streit von csu bis linkspartei auch sein
mag gegen die ft sind sich alle einig
darf das einfach so bleiben
na gut das liegt an der afg aber so wie
sie sich halt bisher im bundestag und in
der öffentlichkeit es ist ja fast
schlimmer außerhalb der
parlamentarischen debatten in den
sozialen netzwerken präsentiert kann ich
gut verstehen dass alle parteien sagen
wir wollen mit einer partei die sich so
wenig klar abgrenzt nach rechts nicht
sehr viel gemeinsamkeit haben dem
parlament selber kriegen wir die
debatten einigermaßen hin was aus dem
parlament heraus in soziale netzwerke
produziert wird das ist oft sehr
ärgerlich wir versuchen immer das mit
den begrenzten instrumentarien die wir
haben so so gut zur vernunft zu machen
es geht aber insgesamt das parlament
funktioniert schon
nun ist er im bundestag das symbol für
die spaltung das immer noch der afg
einen vize präsidenten job oder posten
verwehrt bleibt kann das denn wirklich
auf die dauer so bleiben ist das die
richtige antwort auf immerhin die
demokratische entscheidung von 13
prozent der wähler
der bundestag kann jederzeit seine
geschäftsordnung auch ändern und sagen
wir haben eine bestimmte zahl von vize
präsidenten ob zwei oder drei oder vier
ich glaube auch wenn wir mehr fraktionen
hätten würden wir ja auch irgendwann an
den punkt kommen wo was sagen würden wir
wollen nicht zehn vize-präsidenten denn
das wäre ja auch für die
arbeitsfähigkeit und für alles andere
nicht sehr günstig also dieses prinzip
der seine fraktion im präsidium
vertreten sein muss ist ein sehr
schwaches und deswegen ist eigentlich
das stärkere prinzip das wär
vizepräsident ist also die sitzungen
leidet von allen in seiner entscheidung
anerkannt werden muss und deswegen das
vertrauen aller mitglieder des
bundestags in geheimer wahl braucht der
sicht des tages
und deswegen ist es ebenso ich kann es
nicht ändern ich kann niemanden zwingen
kandidaten der fdp der afc in freier in
geheimer wahl zu wählen
machen wir an dieser stelle einen punkt
oder auch nur ein semikolon ein anderes
thema das nächstes jahr drängt und ihnen
am herzen liegt braucht eine hinführung
bevor wir darüber reden können
es geht um die größe des bundestages die
außer kontrolle geraten kann
der bundestag hat sich schon aufgebläht
von etwa 600 die das gesetz anstrebt auf
jetzt etwa 700 weil das wahlsystem zwei
prinzipien zu verdauen hat die sich
nicht gut vertragen erst mal müssen
abgeordnete die ihren wahlkreis nach
erst stimmen gewonnen haben
selbstverständlich ins parlament aber
vielleicht gewinnt ihre partei mit den
zweitstimmen gar nicht so viele prozent
wie die siegreiche wahlkreiskandidaten
hat und dann beginnen diese auf
blähungen und überhänge das muss sich
ändern sagt nicht nur der
bundestagspräsident 598 abgeordnete
sollten es eigentlich sein
doch aktuell sitzen 709 im bundestag der
grund das wahlsystem einerseits
vergrößern überhangmandate das parlament
sie entstehen wenn eine partei mit der
erststimme mehr direktmandate gewinnt
als ihr nach dem zweitstimmenergebnis
zustehen
die überhangmandate vergrößern das
parlament insgesamt gibt es im bundestag
46 die meisten für die union
sie ändern die prozentuale
zusammensetzung des bundestages und
verzerren das zweitstimmenergebnis das
geht nicht urteilte das
bundesverfassungsgericht schon 2012
einige parteien bekämen mehr macht als
ihm zustehe
andere würden benachteiligt ein neues
wahlrecht müsse her
wie wäre es da mit einem verzicht auf
überhangmandate die abgeordneten hatten
die gegenteilige idee noch mehr
abgeordneter benachteiligte parteien
erhalten als entschädigung
ausgleichsmandaten aktuell 65
die zweitstimmen verhältnisse werden so
wiederhergestellt deutscher
perfektionismus der zu einem parlament
mit aktuell 111 zusätzlichen sitzen
führt und das kann noch viel schlimmer
werden waren unter anderem 100 staats
und verfassungsrechtler in einem
bundestag mit vier fraktionen hat das
noch einigermaßen funktioniert aber dann
kam erst linke und später die afd dazu
und bald können die geltenden
rechenmodelle 1 800 personen bundestag
erzwingen
nur der völlig machtlose volkskongress
des milliardenvolkes china wäre noch
größer
die vernunft verlangt mäßigung aber das
politische spiel verlangt mäßigung immer
bei den anderen und so wird das halt nix
eine momentaufnahme von cornelia schiene
es ist eine politische dauerbaustelle
ein kampf gegen die unvermeidlichen
beharrungskräfte des bestehenden stadt
kompromissbereitschaft zu zeigen wird
seit jahren das schwarze peter spiel
gespielt der ruf des parlaments
ramponiert im herbst 2017 nach der
letzten wahl wurde im bundestag massiv
angebaut
es wurde geschraubt verschoben
zusammengerückt 709 abgeordnete mussten
ihren platz finden
seit amtsantritt fordert
bundestagspräsident wolfgang schäuble
von den parteien eine wahlrechtsreform
bislang ohne erfolg
ich dränge darauf jede woche jeden tag
jetzt auch wieder diesem interview
es muss eine einigung geben es kann
nicht sein dass wir womöglich nach der
nächsten wahl über 800 abgenommen haben
mehrere anläufe scheiterten die kleinen
parteien grüne linke fdp wagen nun
erneut einen vorstoß den bundestag zu
verkleinern
die union blockiert im moment jeden
vorschlag das war auch so in der wahl
rechtskommission von herrn doktor
schäuble die ja ein jahr lang
frank hat und nach ideen und
lösungsvorschlägen gesucht hat man muss
einfach sehen jede fraktion wird
proportional von unserem vorschlag
getroffen
die kleinen parteien wollen den
bundestag bei 6 130 sitzen deckeln
dafür wollen sie die wahlkreise
vergrößern union und spd die fast alle
direktmandate gewinnen lehnen das in
seltener einigkeit ab für uns in die
wahlkreise der ausdruck von bürgernähe
es gibt viel kritik an abgeordneten aber
wenn man einen vor ort zu hause trifft
und kennt dann stellt man
erstaunlicherweise fest die sind gar
nicht so schlimm manchmal sogar fleißig
vor ort unterwegs und werben um stimmen
ich halte ihn für einen rein
interessengeleiteten vorstoß von
parteien die keine wahlkreise gewinnen
die über listen kommen die sich mit
ihren delegierten abstimmen müssen aber
nicht mit dem wähler
mir geht es darum dass der wähler in
seinem wahlkreis seinen abgeordneten
erlebt die wahlkreise noch größer zu
machen die nur dazu dass wir mehr
technokraten haben das will ich nicht
die großen parteien derzeit union und
spd profitieren von der erststimme den
direktmandaten die kleinen von der
zweitstimme den listenplätzen beide
interessen hinter einem gesetz zu
vereinen kommt der quadratur des kreises
gleich
wenn wir 100 deutsche fragen wollt ihr
lieber 800 menschen im bundestag oder
einen etwas größeren wahlkreis dann ist
meine vermutung dass die menschen sagen
lieber einen arbeitsfähigen bundestag
es geht um viel um die glaubwürdigkeit
von politik rund um den willen zum
sparen
schon jetzt kostet der vergrößerte
bundestag den steuerzahler fast eine
milliarde euro pro jahr
der hässliche aber leider richtige
spruch von den fröschen die man nicht
fragen darf wenn man einen sumpf
trockenlegen will passt hier leider aber
es gibt nichts anderes als den bundestag
um den bundestag zu reformieren immerhin
steht dem gerade ein mann vor dem nicht
nur von amts wegen sondern auch wegen
seiner erfahrung und seine
persönlichkeit respekt über
parteigrenzen hinweg entgegengebracht
wird
herr bundestagspräsident wer müsste
jetzt in dieser frage über seinen
schatten springen und tut es nicht die
einen wollen eigentlich ein reines
proportionales system das sind die
parteien die wenig direktmandate
erringen
die anderen die sehr viele direktmandate
jedenfalls in der vergangenheit errungen
haben sagen wir haben ja unsere stärke
unsere vertreter ich bin übrigens auch
so einer sind in ihren wahlkreisen
anerkannt akzeptiert werden gewählt die
bevölkerung würde nicht verstehen wenn
die nicht in den bundestag kommen nicht
aber das ist ja auch so dass eine etwas
verkleinert vergrößerung der wahlkreise
die als lösung angeboten wird ja nun
nicht wirklich das ende der demokratie
bedeuten würde und trotzdem gibt es
parteien die sich dagegen sperren
das wäre doch der goldene weg oder nicht
das wäre das alleine reicht nicht aus
wir brauchen mehrere elemente deswegen
habe ich ja ich habe ja unmittelbar nach
der konstituierung des bundestags schon
2017 die fraktionsvorsitzenden zum
gespräch gebeten
ja noch eine arbeitsgruppe eingesetzt
waren tüchtige neue die werden sehr
intensiv ich habe es selber geleitet mit
wir haben es alle mit viel kompetenz und
geduld gemacht und am ende war klar es
muss bei der politischen bei den
politischen implikationen die das für
jede fraktion hat nicht nur für eine
müssen die fraktionsführungen sich da
auf eine lösung verständigen ich bin
ziemlich zuversichtlich dass wir doch
noch zu beginn des kommenden jahres eine
lösung zustande bringen werden die
jedenfalls sicher stellt dass wir immer
das wahlergebnis ausgeht der bundestag
nicht wesentlich größer wird also jetzt
ist ob es zu einer maske zu einer
deutlichen verkleinerung was ich
begrüßen würde kommen wird dafür wird
die zeit ein bisschen knapp
das kann ja nur was werden wenn die
jetzige das jetzige parlament noch
durchhält und es nicht bald zu neuwahlen
kommt plädieren sie bei weiteren
schwierigkeiten notfalls für eine
minderheitsregierung die wenigstens die
legislaturperiode zu ende bringt na ich
wir werden sehen was wirklich im
augenblick hat man ja den eindruck dass
sich die partner der großen koalition
doch ein stück weit darauf verständigt
haben ihre verantwortung die sie ja zu
beginn des der legislaturperiode
übernommen haben durch das wahlergebnis
durch die regierungsbildung durch die
wahl der bundeskanzlerin durch den
koalitionsvertrag dass sie der gerecht
werden wollen denn unser grundgesetz
daran muss man gelegentlich erinnern hat
aus den bitteren erfahrungen von weimar
ja einmal den schluss gezogen es sollte
eigentlich die wahlperiode generell vier
jahre dauern und nicht beliebig verkürzt
werden können das ist ja auch ein
schwieriger weg fragte zu vorgezogenen
neuwahlen zu kommen
verfassungsrechtlich gar nicht so ganz
einfach und zum anderen nicht deswegen
ja auch die stellung des gewählten
bundeskanzlers oder der gewählten
bundeskanzlerin so stark dass man
genügend möglichkeiten hat aber das
beste ist wir haben ja eine stabile
mehrheit im bundestag wenn die partner
der großen koalition also habe ich den
eindruck auch aus den gesprächen der
vergangenen woche entschlossen sind
diese legislaturperiode erfolgreich zu
ende zu bringen dann ist das sicherlich
für unsere demokratie für unseren
freiheitlichen rechtsstaat die bessere
lösung wenn es anders kommt dann machen
wir neu war aber selbst dann können wir
noch zuvor eine entscheidung treffen die
sicherstellt dass der bundestag nicht
übergroß wird 2020 wird es weisen
dankeschön ein gutes weihnachtsfest
dann geht das selbe ihn wir haben dieses
gespräch am frühen abend geführt und in
teilen kürzen müssen
nachrichten nun von heinz wolf im süden
europas wüten heftige unwetter
mindestens zehn menschen sind ums leben
gekommen in südwestfrankreich waren
heute rund 90.000 haushalte ohne strom
vor allem die küstengebiete in portugal
spanien italien und frankreich sind von
überschwemmungen und orkanböen betroffen
vor sardinien konnte die crew dieses
frachtschiffs per hubschrauber gerettet
werden das sturmtief brachte winde mit
geschwindigkeiten bis zu 170 kilometer
pro stunde
in hongkong hat es bei protesten erneut
gewalt gegeben dieses mal ging es jedoch
nicht um die demokratiebewegung sondern
um chinas vorgehen gegen die uiguren
etwa 1000 menschen bekundeten zunächst
friedlich ihre solidarität mit der
muslimischen minderheit die
menschenrechtlern zufolge im nordwesten
chinas unterdrückt wird als
protestierende eine chinesische fahne
verbrennen wollten kam es zu
auseinandersetzungen mit der polizei
in afghanistan gibt es auch drei monate
nach der präsidenten bei keine klarheit
über die künftige politische führung des
landes
die wahlkommission hat heute zwar ein
vorläufiges ergebnis der wahl
veröffentlicht das sieht amtsinhaber
ghani mit knapp über 50 als sieger aber
sein größter konkurrent regierungschef
abdullah abdullah spricht von wahlbetrug
und er hat die möglichkeit das resultat
anzufechten
mit dem appell jüdischen gemeinden in
deutschland eine lebendige zukunft zu
ermöglichen ist der gemeindetag des
zentralrats der juden in berlin zu ende
gegangen
zugleich gab es heute deutliche kritik
des antisemitismus beauftragten der
bundesregierung felix klein
beleidigungen gegen juden würden von der
justiz nicht konsequent genug verfolgt
heute hat das jüdische lichterfest
chanukka begonnen
hier am größten hannover leichter
europas am brandenburger tor wurde das
erste licht entzündet dass heute das
schicksal der menschen in den elenden
griechischen flüchtlingslagern wieder
thema wurde hat nichts mit
weihnachtlicher rührseligkeit zu tun
dass baut sich seit jahren auf ich kenne
das lager auf lesbos zum beispiel wo
europa schutzbedürftige hinter
drahtverhau in überfüllte lager zwingt
die ärzte ohne grenzen sind dort
rausgezogen auf die andere straßenseite
weil sie kein feigenblatt mehr sein
wollten für die unerträglichen zustände
dort wieder moreno leitet die station
sie hat jahre in den schlimmsten fällen
löcher gearbeitet und das ausgehalten
lesbos weltzien nicht mehr aus weil es
ihr euren kann so muss man darauf
gefasst sein dass jemand stirbt weil
kein chirurg da ist oder medizin nicht
einfach mitten in den busch fliegen kann
aber das hier kann ich nicht ertragen
mehr als 2500 kinder und 6000 erwachsene
bekommen keine medizin in europa es ist
wahnsinn
und warum die leute sagen dass sie so
behandelt werden damit nicht noch mehr
kommen aber es wird genau so weiter
gehen immer mehr die zustände werden
noch schlimmer die menschen kommen nicht
zum vergnügen
wo sie herkommen sind sie in
lebensgefahr sie haben keine wahl
nur diese eine einzige chance tausende
kinder sind in dieser situation sie
wenigstens sollten wir schnellstens dort
rausholen fordert jetzt der grünen
robert habeck
das hat keine aktion gestartet aber
immerhin mal eine neue debatte es ist
kalt es ist matschig das flüchtlingscamp
moria auf der griechischen insel lesbos
ist völlig überfüllt und kein angenehmer
ort besonders die kinder und
jugendlichen leiden die sich ohne hilfe
von erwachsenen durchschlagen müssen
viele stammen aus syrien afghanistan
sie leben irgendwo in den olivenhainen
unter unzureichenden zeltplanen kein
vormund keine schule jemanden der sich
um sie kümmert
die probleme kennen auch politiker
überall in europa und haben sie
teilweise mit eigenen augen gesehen wie
niedersachsens innenminister pistorius
deutschland müsse minderjährige
aufnehmen meint er
die möglichkeit besteht die kapazitäten
sind da also finde ich sollten wir es
auch tun
da kann man dann auch mal herz zeigen
auch kurz vor weihnachten ein paar
kinder aus diesem elend rausholen auch
grünen-chef tarek will diesen schritt
lieber heute als morgen machen notfalls
auch als deutschen alleingang weil die
eu beim thema flüchtlinge so gespalten
ist
wir kennen die blockaden und sicher bald
weihnachten denn wir in der kirche
sitzen und die kollekte wird
eingesammelt und ja sagt ich spende erst
wenn man nebenmann gespendet hat dann es
gibt überhaupt nichts also irgendeiner
muss man voran gehen wesentlich
zurückhaltender die union hilfe vor ort
gerne jahr gültige asylregeln außer
kraft setzen nein ich bin der festen
überzeugung dass ein deutscher
nationaler alleingang jetzt ein falsches
signal wäre weil er die anderen
eu-länder in die
bequemen situation bringen würde sich
zurücklehnen zu können
es bedarf aber eines gemeinsamen
europäischen ansatzes ähnliche appelle
auch von der menschenrechtsbeauftragten
der bundesregierung die neue eu
kommission muss schnell einen neuen
anlauf zu einer fairen verteilung der
geflüchteten unternehmen wünschenswert
wäre auch ein neues schutzprogramm für
unbegleitete minderjährige flüchtlinge
das kann aber dauern und so ist zwei
tage vor weihnachten nicht in sicht das
minderjährige nun schnell nach
deutschland ausreisen können
der beitrag den reporter zu solchen
problemen leisten können ist bescheiden
und sie können nur sagen was ist das
handeln danach oder das nichthandeln
danach ist die verantwortung von anderen
nachrichten noch einmal von 10
ja und damit zum sport an diesem sonntag
in der fußball bundesliga hat fortuna
düsseldorf 2 2 1 gegen union berlin
gewonnen
ebenfalls 2 1 endete das zweite
sonntagsspiel paderborn gegen eintracht
frankfurt bayern münchen hat bekannt
gegeben dass hansi flick trainer bleibt
mindestens bis zum ende der saison ein
verbleib darüber hinaus sei für den fc
bayern
ausdrücklich eine gut vorstellbare
option hieß es weiter
der nordische kombinierer vinzenz geiger
hat sich erneut einen platz auf dem
podest erkämpft beim weltcup in ramsau
in österreich lag nach dem springen von
der normalschanze zunächst auf dem 13
dann aber eine starke laufleistung über
die 10 kilometer
und so musste sich gegen am ende nur den
beiden norwegern reber und groh back
geschlagen geben und skispringer karl
geiger ist in engelberg in der schweiz
beim letzten wettbewerb vor der
vierschanzentournee heute vierter
geworden
gestern hatte er dort bereits platz drei
belegt zählt damit zu den deutschen
hoffnungsträgern für die tournee
gewonnen hat das springen heute der
japaner kobayashi bei der darts wm in
london gab es den nächsten sieg für die
25-jährige fällen scherrer
sie steht nun als erste frau der wm
geschichte in runde drei 3000 zuschauer
im alexandra palace haben einen neuen
liebling fällen sharrock bei ihrem
zweitrundensieg beendet sie die partie
mit dem treffer ins bullseye für den
favorisierten gegner so judith aus
österreich bleibt nur die nebenrolle
wir können die männer schlagen ich habe
zwei hier weggeputzt es gibt so viele
tolle spielerinnen die berufstätige
mutter steht nun unter den 32 besten
spielern der welt
der deutsche max hopp ist in der dritten
runde raus nach 2 1 satzführung
unterliegt er dem litauer lapan oscars
in zwei zu vier sätzen
erstaunliche ergebnisse von diesem sport
verglichen mit der lage der
flüchtlingskinder auf griechischen insel
ist das was heute in frankreich gemüter
bewegt ein first world problem ein
problem der komfortablen ersten welt
aber auch das betrifft kinder die in
frankreich je nach sichtweise zu opfern
der großen streiks oder gewissenloser
arbeitgeber werden sollten
das gab jetzt zu heftigen protest das
regierung unternehmen und gewerkschaften
die sich auf keine reform einigen können
wenigstens dafür eine lösung fanden
400 kilometer autofahrt haben corelli
und ihre tochter um 8 uhr heute morgen
schon hinter sich
eigentlich sollte es gestern aus der
normandie zu ihrem vater nach
südfrankreich fahren aber anfang der
woche hatte die französische
bahngesellschaft sncf die tickets mit
begleitservice für alleinreisende kinder
annulliert bis einschließlich
weihnachten
sowas haben wir einfach nur gewartet und
dann nach irgend einer lösung gesucht
1200 kilometer mit dem auto quer durch
frankreich wäre eine alternative gewesen
zum glück kam dann die nachricht dass
die bahn heute sonderzüge für kinder
einsetzt allerdings nur von und nach
paris
seit 18 tagen wird in frankreich
gestreikt um gegen die rentenreform der
regierung makro zu protestieren
obwohl die unterstützung der franzosen
für die streiks leicht zurückgeht liegt
sie laut umfragen immer noch bei über 50
prozent
für kuranyi ist das verständlich
wenn man damit nicht konfrontiert ist
geht es aber wenn man kleine kinder hat
die ihren vater in den ferien sehen
wollen und das immer so chaotisch ist
dann ist das ganz schön anstrengend
zumal wir uns früh umzug tickets
gekümmert hatten
die bahn begründete die annulierung des
begleitservice mit dem streik die
sicherheit an den bahnhöfen und in den
zügen könne nicht garantiert werden
die gewerkschaft cgt die seit gut zwei
wochen die bahn streiks in frankreich
mitträgt schob den schwarzen peter
zurück
es ist er wieder dieser begleitservice
der kinder wird nicht von sncf
angestellten geleistet sondern von
angestellten einer firma die nicht
streiken
wenn er also während der ferien nicht
stattfindet ist das nicht wegen der
streikenden sondern weil die sncf die
kosten senken will
kurios bleibt in den vierzehn
sonderzügen von heute waren von 5.000
plätzen nur 1000 belegt viele familien
hatten inzwischen bustickets oder
mitfahrgelegenheiten organisiert trotz
verstopfter straßen und erhöhter preise
oder sie hatten umgeplant und
weihnachten zb bei den großeltern
gecancelt über einen platz in den halb
leeren zügen hätten sich allerdings
viele franzosen gefreut denn auch heute
fährt wieder nur jeder zweite tv und nur
jeder vierte intercity zug noch
dreieinhalb stunden zugfahrt und 200
weitere autokilometer dann ist für
endlich weihnachten bei papa
eine gute woche dieses wechselvolle jahr
2019 noch zu bieten
das sind tagen in denen man sich mehr
noch als sonst ins eigene zurückzieht
ins eigene leben familie freunde und von
den ereignissen die da draußen absehbar
sind eine auswahl von christian kirsch
zugverbindung auf die krim schon morgen
das kündigt russland an soll die
annektierte schwarzmeer halbinsel krim
von russland aus per zug erreichbar sein
über die neu gebaute brücke über die
straße von kertsch ein zeichen der
einheit so putin ein zeichen der
völkerrechtswidrigen addition so die
ukraine
seit fünf jahren sind alle bestehenden
bahnlinien auf die krim blockiert hacker
kongress in leipzig ab freitag trifft
sich der chaos computer club zur größten
hacker konferenz europas und 17.000
teilnehmer debattieren rund um das thema
cybersicherheit angriffe auf it systeme
werden immer komplexer und massiver
anlass genug nach neuen
sicherheitsstrategien für die digitale
welt zu suchen
[Musik]
abschied von laura dahlmeier siebenfache
weltmeisterin zweimal olympisches gold
einer der erfolgreichsten biathletinnen
überhaupt am samstag dann das endgültige
ende einer großartigen karriere
da wird sie noch einmal antreten auf
kunstschnee im stadion in gelsenkirchen
die letzten meter in der loipe großer
abschied für eine große sportlerin
und noch der ausblick auf das nicht
besonders winterliche wetter morgen
meist stark bewölkt und vor allem im
westen und süden auch etwas regen in den
alpen oberhalb von etwa 900 metern
schnee bei lebhaftem westwind 4 bis 10
grad
auch an heiligabend und am ersten
feiertag eher nass und windig bei fünf
bis elf grad am zweiten feiertag wieder
freundlicher und etwas kälter noch
zweimal schlafen sagen kinder noch
einmal senden sagt das heute journal
dann ist weihnachten bestimmt haben sich
alle vorgenommen die hektik am letzten
vollen geschäftstag morgen in grenzen zu
halten versuchen wir es und dann
berichten wir ihnen am abend vielleicht
sind sie ja da wir sind hier das heute
noch einen schönen abend
[Musik]